[Musique]
on soir des enfants bonsoir il commence
à faire chaud dans le ciel on voit que
les vacances approchent subles vos
chronos du calme nounours décents plutôt
voir nos amis petit louis et mirabel rue
et hop
mon échelle propos propre approche vais
encore transpiré pour enfants papa port
jour mes petits amis bonjour tu sais
qu'on a vraiment très attendue
aujourd'hui
oh oui on est allé au jardin zoologique
au jardin zoologique
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça ben
c'est le zoo au bond et on évite des
lions formidable j'aime pas beaucoup ces
animaux là c'est pas du tout ça
bien sûr que c'est pour rire bien sûr
qu'on fait pas de façon passons de soi y
avait aussi des yeux
vraiment il y avait des bébés ont des
yeux ressens c'est tellement jolie les
bébés ou pris dans ma famille ma soeur
emilia à trois beaux petits oursons
c'est une belle sa miss
tu ne les montre jamais sont encore trop
petit ils prennent encore leurs biberons
mais quand ils seront plus grands
je voulais âmes aimerait lever les fonds
lui manger des cacahuètes t cacahuètes
il était sage et aussi en 2d cacahuètes
on est lassé il les attraper oui mais
tous les bébés même pas les cacahuètes
dit tu vas premier au zoo quelquefois je
suis allé une fois ne se bat pas bien
plus il ya des messieurs en casquette et
ils ont couru derrière en criant autre
appel à notre appel
et pourtant j'avais payé mon enquête
avait un peu perdu
c'est pour rire où vous avez vouloir
suivre vous à trois fois par an
cette fois je me tiens on est gâté les
juifs y trouvera les coquins ils m'ont
bienvenue donc mais vite les enfants
bonne nuit bonne nuit gros france à
manier kilimira b
[Musique]
allons allons mes amis il est l'heure de
dormir à te voilà gros ours ou le patron
n'a pas honte d'avoir peur d'un faux
lion sont terribles faisant fort bonne
eu des enfants embrasser bien fort vos
parents allaient sagement au lit et fait
de doux rêves
bonne nuit à demain demain
[Musique]